Roy Nicolet, how are you doing?
I'm doing wonderful, Michael.
It's Friday afternoon.
I'm feeling great.
How are you?
I am feeling just fine.
I miss not seeing you on Stanford campus.
Yeah. Well, they closed down campus.
That we're not a long time ago.
Well, Roy, I'm excited to learn more
about your journey and share your journey.
We've gotten to know each other
quite well over this past year
as you were finishing your business degree
at Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Quite an experience, I'm sure,
which I can't wait to hear more about.
But you have such
a phenomenal life experience.
And all these different things
that you've done,
transitioning from a leader in the IDF,
to Intel, to studying in the Technion.
So many different things,
all the way leading up to Stanford
that I'd love to just
talk about your life, and perhaps,
touch on the different events
and draw some nuggets
that you now take with you
on your entrepreneurial journey.
How does that sound?
Sounds great.
Roy, who are you?
Who am I?
Roy, I'm 34 years old,
Israeli entrepreneur,
born and raised in Even Yehuda,
and I think that being Israeli
is a big part of my life.
Why do you say that?
Why do I say that?
Being Israeli means
you connect yourself with a country,
with your Jewish heritage.
You live it.
You're born as an individual,
but you experience your country
and so, such big intensities
from serving your country
and also being pissed about politics.
I think that it's unique being Israeli.
Of course. 100%.
So, talk to me a little bit
about your experience
at Stanford Business School.
You've started two years ago,
you are coming from Israel,
you mentioned that
it was almost a life dream
to go there, right?
Yeah.
So, Stanford Business School
was a life dream of,
about six years that I plan
to go to Stanford GSB.
And what's incredible about Stanford is
that you interact with amazing people.
You're getting inspired on a daily basis.
You have the professors.
It's really different
from the Israeli experience
of studying in college.
The professors know you.
They'll have coffee with you.
Hopefully they'll invest in you
in the future,
but they're very very generous
with their time and knowledge.
So, Stanford is incredible.
The people that are being there,
everybody breathes entrepreneurship.
You get inspiration from Silicon Valley
is just this is the place to be
for an entrepreneur, I think.
Okay. So, now I what I would love to do
is to talk about different parts
of your life and the different experiences
that from there,
because just before we started this call,
you mentioned that looking back
and reflecting on these
different experiences,
good and bad experiences,
you've accumulated these nuggets,
that now, as you're creating your startup
and you're now the founder
of a startup in stealth mode,
now you're using these experiences
to move forward.
So I'd love to open the floor
and let you guide me through
these different adventures
that you've had.
Cool. So, I'll mention that
I'm working on a startup right now.
It's an AI powered startup.
And it's in stealth mode,
so I can't talk about it too much.
But it's my second startup.
And I didn't understand
where the resilience
and not losing hope came from.
How the hell am I waking up in the morning
and grinding on, getting clients,
getting validation from investors
and getting rejected on a daily basis,
but also continuing moving forward
until I get the success
from every distress.
And I realized that basically,
being an entrepreneur,
the entrepreneurial thing in me
was very much influenced
by my military service.
So, I had a very broad military service
starting from pilot school,
and then I went to be a tank fighter,
and then an intelligence officer,
in one of the
intelligence officer positions.
Crazy, Roy. That's just crazy.
From the pilot academy,
one of the most prestigious areas
in the IDF,  going to be in a tank,
which is an extraordinary experience,
all the way to be an intelligence officer.
Another position that is sought after
by so many people going into the military.
Sorry, but continue. I'm just impressed
by the variety of experiences
that you've had.
Thank you.
So my first military officer position
was in a commando unit, Sayeret Golani.
And in Sayeret Golani,
one of the values is you'll get a mission,
a certain mission.
It will seem unrealistic to perform it,
but you will go and do it.
And you have a certain limited time
to plan your mission
and you'll find so many creative ways.
But at the end of the day,
you'll execute the mission
even if you're not ready.
And that was very very inspiring for me.
You find out in many cases
and every night
that you don't have the solution.
Yet, you need to march forward,
you need to perform the task.
And sometimes just by having the hope
that everything will be fine
and you'll just go and do it, by that,
you did like 90% of the job.
Right.
Not to say that these are
dangerous missions and entrepreneurship
is way not like this.
But the mentality really taught me a lot
moving forward today.
Another thing is that
you go to a military mission
and you don't really have
all the intelligence,
you don't really have all the information
about the other side
to execute the mission.
But yet you go and do that,
you take the risk.
And many times
wherever you work somewhere,
whether you lead a company,
you need to cope with uncertainty.
You won't have all the answers.
You won't have all the information
to take a calculated decision.
But this is why people trust us,
this is why people pay us salaries.
So, I learned that, I guess,
in Sayeret Golani, yeah.
That's just incredible.
So, you go through
these experiences in the IDF,
and obviously, as a leader,
there's a lot of analogies to be made,
and a lot of connections to be made
leading a company, a product,
and leading a mission,
leading a team in the army.
And I think one of the special things
that I also experienced in the IDF
was the idea that,
you don't go there
you don't work for money
and the whole promotion ladder thing,
it's so different from the way
that we are in and we really learn
what it means to motivate
and what it means to lead by example.
Those are two of the biggest ideals
of the army, and I'm sure that
you're an exemplary leader
in your startup now
and taking a lot of these
insights from there.
Talk to me about another life adventure
where you've learned
something interesting for your startup.
Another life adventure,
oh, I'm blacking out right now.
When you look at yourself
as an entrepreneur now,
you mention that
there are various experiences
that you've taken lessons from there
and now you're implementing them
in your day to day life
as an entrepreneur,
whether it be rejection or leadership
or vision or creativity.
So, I'd love to get more insight
into what other areas
that you've gained this inspiration for.
Yeah.
So, what I really enjoy
at the end of the day
when I'm working with people,
my co-founder,
the people that we work with,
is not forgetting that they are people.
It's really important for me
to talk to people,
even go to small details.
And that was another lesson
taught by another position
that I had in my military service.
So, I had this soldier,
I will keep his name anonymous,
and he used to come
to my office every day,
feeling terrible.
And I suspected
that something was wrong
and perhaps he was suicidal.
With a lot of heart and dedication,
I sat down with him.
But there are some people who need help
and they are around us all the time.
And what happened
with this particular soldier
that he told me that he wants
to end his life, eventually.
And that life lesson, specifically,
So, I'll tell you that the journey
of being a commander in the IDF
was very very special
when you interact with your soldiers.
So, I have led around 80 soldiers
in my military service.
And as a commander,
you are sometimes their best friend,
sometimes their enemy.
You are representing the system.
A system that forces people
to serve in the military.
Not everybody wants to be there.
Not everybody is an officer
who wants to volunteer,
not everybody does effort
to their careers to be a leader.
And these special relationships
that you have, sometimes you encounter
in situations where you are a psychologist
to suicidal soldier,
or whether you are in a couple of therapy
if your soldiers are dating each other.
You're a social worker
if the background of your soldier
is from the very hard situation.
You go to their places
and see how they live.
Sometimes they are a pillar
because the military missions,
when you need to sleep somewhere,
you have a tendency to nap.
I think that
what you are touching on here,
which is very very true,
the IDF is a compulsory service
which brings with it
a lot of the challenges
of what it means to lead
within a program like this
where every person enlists.
And then naturally,
when the whole organization is very young,
because the majority of the organization
is 18 to 21 year olds,
you have very young leaders.
So, at the age of 19, you get a team
of eight to 10 people and say,
"Okay, welcome."
You are now their sibling, their parent,
their psychologists, their social worker.
And you have to now, all of a sudden,
understand what that means.
And I can totally relate
to these lessons
that you're sharing about.
About how you're learning
to lead by example
and to be a commander that way.
Now that you've gone through
Stanford Business School as well,
in the school where a lot of the classes
are about leadership and about management
and how to successfully lead a business,
talk to me a little bit about
the differences between
leading a team in the Army
rather than leading a team, perhaps,
at a startup or in a business.
And you've also got a chance
to work at a few companies,
so you also have that experience as well.
Yeah. So, leading people by example
is definitely one of these.
And also understanding that
at the end of the day,
these are people.
You need to understand
what is the motivation behind the people,
even in your startup.
Everybody has their own
need to give an input, need to impact,
they have their own passions.
And learning what is their motivation
is like the best leadership skill
that I learned in the military.
Another thing is working as a team.
So, in many ways,
the social connections that teams have
are really like perpetuate
the energy and commitment
to the company and the mission.
Yeah.
And I think that
it's sometimes overlooked
because people want to work
and they have their work-life balance.
In the military, you live within work
and the people that you're stuck with,
you're working with them
and you go to your room
and you stay with them in the same room.
So, everywhere that I go,
I try to bring that team cohesiveness
and try to lower the guards of people
so they can feel comfortable.
How do you do that?
How do you lower guards of people
so that your teammates
can be comfortable?
So, I believe that encouraging
open discussion.
So, I know that you were an officer
in the Israeli Defense Forces
as an intelligence officer.
And we have a big story about
not saying what you have in mind.
You need to always say
what you have in mind
and to think that it's important.
So, you always need
to encourage a discussion
if it's relevant to how we work
and what are we working on.
And so, always encourage people to talk,
to be open about these things.
We don't want to hold any aggression
towards the goal or the team,
so this is super important.
Second thing is that,
we need to stay in work
until work is done.
Because eventually,
sometimes we need to deliver.
And some of that military experience
brought me to understand
that I need to stay with my employees
and support them and my team.
Which is something that you see
in the military all the time.
Right.
And supporting them and create a synergy
that they feel more motivated,
they feel supported,
and they're not alone.
100%. I completely resonate
with what you're saying.
Talk to me a little bit
about the GSB experience.
So, you mentioned a little bit
about the entrepreneurship side of it,
about the social side of it.
I'd love to really hear,
because I haven't gone
through the GSB myself,
and so many other friends.
We all really want to.
But it's a little far.
And while we hope to get in one day,
you now have the opportunity
to share with me having just finished it.
So, talk to me a little bit about
the good, the bad and the ugly.
The good, the bad and the ugly.
The good, it's an incredible
open community.
So, the GSB is very special.
People are encouraged to share,
be vulnerable and support each other.
So, that's wonderful.
We have once a week,
we have two classmates doing a talk.
30 minutes dedicated all to them
sharing their life story.
And you see those people in class
and they are super smart.
And then you go to talk and you hear
incredible stories of growth
facing adversity.
And people are incredible.
Second thing about this university,
that it's really not competitive,
which is good,
so we have a great nondisclosure.
You don't feel any competition.
People are just helping each other.
Which I think is interesting
because it's extremely competitive
to get into.
The acceptance rate
is one of the lowest in the world.
Yet the second you're in,
you're a part of this community
that you're saying
it's not competitive, right?
It's true.
And, it's the lowest percent
out of getting in the programs.
And this great non-disclosure
allows people to just
not think about race, just study,
be focused on their friends,
get together, collaborate, take risks.
It's encourage you to do mistakes
because eventually you will graduate.
Right. So you mentioned
a few times also to me,
outside of this is that
the part of the magic of the GSB is that
you have all these people who are coming
from extremely different backgrounds.
You're coming in
as an officer from the IDF,
you have people coming in
after they've run businesses
around the world
or had different adversities
that they've overcome.
And when you come into an institution
that there are no grades are involved,
you each have your own personal grade,
but the goal at the end
is to graduate together as a community
and to build relationships
that will expand way beyond the campus,
but in the real world
and in the business world, right?
Exactly. I will move to the bad.
The bad thing is that it's only two years.
It's only two years. I love that.
It's only two years.
So, it's a paradise for education.
You're getting inspired every day.
It's a tremendous growth.
Like I was basically half vacationing,
traveling with friends.
And still I feel like I boosted my career
and grew as an entrepreneur
and only two years.
I wish it was cheaper and longer, I guess.
Was it worth working for six years
to get in for this two year experience?
I believe so.
I'm pretty biased, as you know.
I've put a lot of money
in this program, too.
So you have to believe that
it gives you something.
But looking backwards, two years ago,
coming from Israel,
even with my fluent English,
I didn't know how it would grow me
to be where I am today.
I feel comfortable fundraising now
with top VCs, collaborating
and selling my products to clients.
That boosted my confidence greatly.
And so I'm grateful for that.
Also, this community's incredible.
So much knowledge, so much grace,
people are helping all the time.
Which I think it's really really,
I wish my alma mater, Technion,
would be more like this.
That people would collaborate more,
the alumni network.
We have so much time in Technion
and they still haven't picked up
about building a community
that helps their members.
I think that
the interesting thing is that,
in Israel,
the equivalent of the community experience
of a university is your army unit.
Because when we go to
the average bar in Tel Aviv,
you don't really ask,
"Hey, where did you go to school?"
You ask,
"Hey, which unit did you serve in?"
In the US, obviously,
it's the first question.
And so I think that it's so interesting
to see two different communities,
two different countries,
two different incredible countries
with people growing up in different ways.
But at the end,
it's all about the community
and it's all about the people.
Roy, one thing you mention to me,
which I would love to bring up,
you told me that
every really amazing CEO
has their shtick,
they have their thing.
And you ask me,
"Michael, what is it going to be
your thing?"
Well, Roy, I'm going to turn
the question to you,
because this is about you.
What is your thing as the CEO?
Cool. So, I'll go wild and I say that
I'm going to be the jungle CEO.
So, every CEO is crazy.
My office's going to be all about nature.
We're going to have trees,
we're going to have animals
jumping around, monkeys, tigers
running in the office.
And I'll be,
Elon Musk is a space guy,
I'm going to be nature guy.
What are you going to be?
I have no idea yet.
I 'm going to see how yours plays out
and then I'll make my decision.
I mean, you've also really inspired me
to be more conscious
about my eating habits and meditation.
And it's not just about nature,
I think one thing that
I've gotten to know about you
over this past year is this idea
of like being of inner collectiveness
and an inner calmness
and really being in touch
with who you are.
So, I want to thank you
for bringing that to my attention,
because both of us reflect often
on how driven we are
and how much time we spend
on racing to something.
Yet at the same time,
you're very conscious
and also introspection
and taking the time to really reflect.
And I really appreciate
that you brought that reflection
into my life
because these are not mutually exclusive
racing to something
and being happy internally
and being satisfied.
Roy, I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
Before we leave, I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Okay.
Jews, entrepreneurial,
Israeli and loving,
because I have a lot of love in me.
100%.
And I can testify from the past year
watching you both in the classroom
and also outside in the social scene,
it resonates.
I can't wait to see
the incredible things that you do
and be part of each other's journeys.
So, thank you very very much
for taking the time to be here.
Thank you, Michael.
Take care